تبين واضح في التصريحات بين عبد الفتاح
البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان حميتي التباين
يدور حول الاتفاق الايطالي ووضع قوات
الدعم السريع وقررت البرهان في الخامس
والعشرين من اكتوبر عام 2021
اعلن صراحه دعمه للاتفاق الايطالي الموقع
بين قوى مدنيه ابرزها قوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي والمكون العسكري بصيغه
الراهنه محذرا من فتح الباب امام عوده
عناصر النظام المعزول للحكم خطا انقلاب 25
اكتوبر ليصبح للاسف بوابه لعوده النظام
البائد مما دفعني لعدم التردد بان اعود
عنه الى الصواب بان هذه العمليه السياسيه
قد تطاول زمنها
وان الوقت قد حان لانهائها والوصول لحل
سياسي نهائي
لكن الرئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان شدد في وقت سابق على ان دعم الجيش
للاتفاق الايطالي يكون وفق رؤيه الجيش وهو
مرهون بتنفيذ بند دمج قوات الدعم السريع
داخل الجيش
حرب التصريحات كما يصفه البعض هنا بين
المسؤولين العسكريين تصل الى مرحله
التحذير من ان التراجع عن الاتفاق
الايطالي قد يؤدي الى تقسيم البلاد
بينما يرى اخرون في مجلس السياده ان القوه
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي غير كافيه
لحل الازمه السياسيه في البلاد وينادون
بفتح الباب لضم اطراف اخرى وهذا الصراع هو
صراع قياده وليس صراع قاعده وبالتالي
ينتهي في تقدير بانتهاء مرحله التسويه
وتحديد مكان الرجلين من العمليه السياسيه
الحاليه التي تدور في السودان حاله من
الشد والجذب وتصريحات متباينه بين العسكر
قد تزيد من تعقيدات المشهد في البلاد التي
تعاني هشاشه امنيه واقتصاديه يصعب التكهن
بما الاتاتها الطهر المرضي الجزيره
الخرطوم